welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz today i'm
really excited to be joined by kane
webster who is the sales director for
bright purple who are a specialist tech
and business change consultancy that
work with businesses across scotland the
uk
and beyond ken started his recruitment
career in 2013 after having a stint in
hospitality as a restaurant supervisor
but over the last nine years he has
taken his recruitment career from
resourcer to team lead to principal
to sales manager and for the last two
years he's now been the sales director
for bright purple so
he now has an oversight of the entire
sales floor
he's responsible for driving the bright
purple culture and standards across
these teams and has a real active role
in helping the business go to the next
level um and really involved in hiring
exceptional talent to join the company
so kane thanks for uh joining me on the
podcast
thank you for having me
looking forward to this one as i said i
think you might be the second
scot that i've had on the podcast
i have deliberately wore
yeah
got a nice tartan shirt on there he's uh
scottish and proud absolutely loved it
so
where we like to start uh on this
podcast kane is is the million pound
question so
what i would love to hear from you with
your sort of nine years context and
experience so far like what what
characteristics and traits do you think
make up a highly successful recruitment
consultant in today's market do you feel
um yeah today's market is probably
probably a valuable and snippet there
because it's definitely changing a
little bit
yeah um
innovative for today's market i would
say um
ability to adapt to new technologies and
as a running joke and break purple i'm a
technophobe uh
you've got some issues there in me
yeah
i run an i.t recruitment agency um
it says the field director and i had a
nokia 3310 until last year and then i
realized i know
and then i realized when i got my
smartphone and just how behind the times
i was and so being committed to that
kind of um ever-changing landscape as a
recruiter i mean linkedin is key yeah
and embracing all these new
technological advances and not being
left behind
is key as well there's so many new tools
software tools you can be using so we
trial we try out two or three new kind
of software packages every year and two
don't work one do and we take that
forward with us so so always being open
to change is really really key but
for people starting to clear out i would
say
it's the obvious one that it's
perseverance and
this idea that you can join and bill
100k or make earn 100k even billing 100k
is hard enough in your first year and so
to earn 100k in your first year and
anyone that's done that hats off to them
i've not met them and so perseverance
and understanding that it's a journey
not not a quick fix or a quick win um it
really is a journey in recruitment you
have to learn your stripes you can't be
told all answers you've really got to
learn
through hard work and mistakes and
what what the answers are and what the
process is like so perseverance is
definitely my biggest advice to people
adopting and not being scared of new
technology
and as many advice we use totally
different platforms from what we did
only eight nine years ago yeah yeah
innovative being open-minded open to
change adaptable and as you see yeah
perseverance okay
so
obviously what we're gonna unpack here
is your nine-year journey right so this
probably it probably feels like a whole
big blur to you right like the probably
last 18 months feel like a bit of a
blood it definitely does for me let
alone the last whole
nine years so i guess where where i just
want to start then
is just to think about the beginning
like how i think there's always an
interesting story just really quickly
like how the hell did you end up did you
end up serving some recruiters in the
restaurant and like what's the story
going from hospitality to getting your
job at bright purple
well i must be the only person i know
that actively tries to get into
recruitment and found it hard um i had
four interviews that i was rejected from
i think my first one was with michael
page and i got to the final stage i was
rejected
and then i tried hydrogen group and
edinburgh got rejected he's got rejected
why did you get rejected
did you get feedback do you get
candidate feedback
yeah the first feedback was then this is
genuinely feedback that was too fluffy
too fluffy wow
that was one of the feedback the other
one was that i didn't have any
experience shots
yeah
always that's a bit off though you got
that experience yes
and
one of them i want i won't name names i
don't want to put under the bus one of
them actually said they'd like to offer
me but they'd like me to go get
experience elsewhere first so i'd get
trained for free
wow what's your fault
question
yeah interesting
so
rejected then how why so how did so
bright purple was the one and go yeah
okay we're going to give you a chance
they were the first one to give me a
chance yeah i started out as a
entry-level resourcer and i had a really
really tough start to my career i didn't
do a deal in four months i think really
and and i was working harder and later
than anybody i was doing all the things
i could do but i just i couldn't get a
break i had 10 finances interviews fall
what on their faces
yeah 10 in a row 10 in a row right let's
talk about this then so we've so you
wanted to get into recruitment
let's just get straight to this because
i think this would be really helpful for
people
uh
why didn't you quit
well i was lucky enough i was working in
the restaurant trade and i was i
graduated in 2008 okay so that was uh
that was the end of booming bus corner i
graduated in the middle of a recession
so i went traveling for five years and
worked in bars and restaurants and i
thought i was making quite good money if
i'm being honest with you and i felt
quite good about myself
and then one of my friends and michael
court he was working in recruitment and
he um
he was just
his career was really taken off and he
was really really young and i remember
always looking up to them and thinking
wow you're doing you're doing so good
like for the age of our mid mid 20s and
you're already like
running teams of people yeah
big deals and and it was attractive to
me i'll be honest i was quite um i was
quite proud of him yeah as a friend
so i knew long term if i stuck it out i
could be like him as a real truth so i
kept going and i kept going and i kept
going and when i was having these 10
rejections at final stage offers i knew
i knew i was doing something right
because i was getting against that part
yeah yeah
yeah i was falling over the final hurdle
and and and you know sometimes the kind
that was rejecting that sometimes the
client was changing the jobs back and
when you're new you don't get the the
hottest or the coolest lows so to get
ten final stages even though i didn't
get a deal in the first four months to
get ten final stages with the hardest
rules in the company because that that
is the reality for people starting out
in their clearly get given they get
given they kind of cut your teeth
[Applause]
so
i was learning my trade and i knew i
knew i was doing something right because
i was i was getting me all my kpis i was
getting interviews and then in one five
and six i think i was the top top um
kind of performer in months five and six
i've done something i've done like a
quarters target in a month
and a quarter starts clicking
i started to sign my own clients as well
i was cut loose as a resource and i was
kind of they kind of said um you know
what you're a great resourcer but you're
not in the back of the net so to speak
so why don't you go try and try and win
your own clients and see if that changes
things and own the relationships but you
need to go on your own
and i did i did it straight away and and
that that was the real changing point
yeah i was allowed to when i was allowed
to be myself and not kind i read from a
script as much and actually and be
myself but the reason i didn't quit i
had examples of of my friends who who
were successful i could see people in
the company like my mentor craig fraser
who was having great success in the
company and so i knew you could be
successful at recruitment and i was
seeing other people doing it and i
wasn't doing much different than them
right okay
yeah yeah so
i put down a bad luck and just kept then
what i don't know
myself so do just uh
let me know if if you like what it was
just actually the the client piece or
something else but like you know those
because thinking like there might be
people listening right now that might be
experiencing or going through what
you're talking about hopefully it's not
10 in a row because that's [ __ ]
savage
but like what so obviously it seems like
owning the client relationship had an
impact but was it like looking if we
were to just think now like anything
else that you think
like oh if i did if i focus on this more
or whatever what what what was it that
you think
enabled you not to hit the back of the
net that could help people listen to
this hopefully hit the back of the net
totally well
i i put clients on a pedestal initially
so yeah very common when i was working
on clients i treated them different than
candidates and it took me a long time to
realize candidates clients aren't just
candidates and a different kind of in
guys yeah yeah
when i stopped writing a long-winded
emails and just being really direct and
answering your questions i found i got a
lot more kind of replies and feedback
and from from clients when i was
emailing them directly and
spotting trends and patterns before i'd
be given a role and and i'd work out and
i'd get two cvs over and the client
would say oh more cvs and i'd go oh okay
and after this baby
or the taker just
yeah exactly i was an order taker and
and i felt i looked busy and i was busy
and i felt busy and i felt like i was
delivering because i was hitting my kpis
but i wasn't really results i wasn't
hitting i wasn't getting deals over the
line of placing people into jobs i was
just hitting kpis and getting cvs and
the client the clients were happy they
were like we've got nine cvs for this
job great and and then i slowly realized
kane why are you sending and nine cvs
for a job why if you sent two really
good cds for a perm tech role which are
hard to find and the client is not
coming back with interview availability
here you know and buying sounds why do i
keep working that role so i started to i
started to kind of you know um
treat clients how they were treating me
so if a client was good with me and
giving me all the information
and moving fast then i would i would
stick with them if a client was becoming
a bit of a black hole if that makes
sense
or not back or kept delaying interviews
then i'd focus my attention that was
where yeah so it took me three or four
months to realize that she's got a
client asks you to work the road doesn't
mean you have to um if a client asks you
to work for robot but is behaving in a
way that isn't you know good for you
yeah you're not working on community
clients
yeah exactly that so i started to grade
my clients and then and as i was i was
really committed to the job i was really
yeah the job is i i i had this mentality
of
work i was working like half eight or
seven pm every night because my
mentality was put in the hard yards
early and that way you you'll progress
your career quicker so i knew i was
doing all the right things and i knew i
was given 110
i was given and i was getting better
each day and so i started to realize
that the clients that i worked with i
could kind of be a bit more selective
with and if they weren't giving you
valued your time you valued your time
and this is really common
time exactly yeah whereas when you start
you start your um journey in recruitment
you you definitely have this idea that
the client is here yeah yeah yeah yeah
your order taker and you and the client
says are happy great but at the end of
the day my boss wasn't because my boss
was going how many how many why have you
changed how many people actually placed
it's all very well sending free cds and
writing three great cover letters and
knowing their dog's name but if the
client's not giving you feedback on the
cv
what and what you're going to do today
you're going to keep working that role
are you kidding and i'd be like yeah and
they'd be like well come on think yeah
yeah for yourself
okay the penny can just walk yeah any
kind of drop a little nice i love that
so plenty of things to take away there
so just just to frame this up so
today right now how many people are you
responsible for how many people do you
manage or do you have direct reports
from just let's just frame it where you
are today
i've got four people that are reporting
to me yeah and under those four people
that is
five people are reporting okay sorry
what do you think i forgot
and underneath
about 15 okay we'll probably have it
probably responsible for about 20 people
overall but five that are reported yeah
so you the road that you're in now as i
said in the introduction like so your
part of your role is to get the most out
of your leaders and so you're now in a
position where you're like supporting
the lead like get given the leaders of
support and then i guess part of your um
role will also be sort of offering
support to the wider
team but your obviously first part is
making sure like the five leaders are
getting everything that they need
support that they they need all of that
right and then you're also now
involved in like business
decisions and where the business is
going as well right
spot on yeah yeah so
yeah in theory i should only have five
people contact me but the reality is
that's not true i probably have 20
people i'll probably touch base with all
20 on a daily basis almost yeah okay so
enjoy it it's good like i've been doing
with the same company nine years yeah
it's amazing yeah i think it's great so
so that that's where it is today so like
let's sort of unpack some of the sort of
i guess key milestones right and there
so from what from what i can see
um on linkedin obviously first two years
it seemed like
you were just like an individual
contributor all you had to worry about
was yeah just getting the most out of
your clients doing deals all of that is
that right
yeah cool 100
on a journey yeah and then after that
and then and then after that was you
then always in some sort of like billing
leadership type of role after that point
yeah i went straight i worked at a
permanent team okay i'd recommend anyone
anyone that starts their career it's
very hard to learn this career in a
contract desk so i worked in a permanent
team under under um craig fraser and
then um i moved into a contract desk
after year one um under a tony summers
and and then
that that gave me an ability to both
business develop because in parameters a
lot of business development yeah and it
gave me the ability to work work very
very fast because contract is very very
fast so initially um i started out kind
of just just a lone wolf going out one
of my own clients servicing them yeah in
the mid level and then i went straight
into a team leader role and because the
business needed it and the business had
a bit of turbulence and my second year i
had a lot of levers and because i think
they went and started their own company
yeah
the other company didn't work out and
but as well as they were good people are
just going to work out for them and but
i left a big opportunity for me um so
when a lot of the business left i
thought well
they offered me a leave with them i
won't pretend to do them but at the same
time i was like well why would i i mean
you guys are leaving and there's going
to be a big big
opportunity yeah
great and that's the other advice i'll
give to people um
you know people say it's luck and time
in recruitment it really really is but
it's the perseverance to stick around
for women's opportunities yeah
yeah so when when that opportunity
presented itself i
i i stepped into it and and
i let my personality really come through
and i put my heart and soul into it
really yeah and so since you've been in
a leadership position
in a leadership position after a year
two and two and a half years
after two and a half years i went into a
leadership position but like i say
that was um luck and timing yeah yeah
yeah and it was very very hard because i
owned a leadership position with not
much mentoring originally because a lot
of good good people or senior people had
left but again
i was thrown in the deep end and
i swam very very hard and very very fast
for very very long and eventually i
learned everything you had to learn on
the job yeah yeah yeah well so we're
gonna dive into that so so and then
right now are you so right now and
throughout that period of you always
like
have you always been doing deals at some
point or are you like really far
attached to that now are you still doing
deals now
like that's um a running joke in the
business because i fought for years to
be as hands-on
okay okay so when i got made sales
manager i actually i've never asked for
a promotion really i've never asked for
one and i've actually turned them down
and then been asked to do them and
follow down the line and agreed because
i thought okay yeah you're right i
should probably do this so when i they
asked me sales manager first time i said
no
and then six months later i said okay
i'll do this but i don't want to lose my
hands on capability so i put my title
hands on yeah yeah i can see that what
did why did you why did you want to lose
it is you scared of like
not being current would you like did is
it because you enjoyed that part of the
job
well coming through my career um i
always there's a lot of middle
management and recruitment there's a lot
of people that look busy that aren't
really speaking to candidates or signing
clients and and the sales floor and i
never really had a lot of respect for
that okay
i always liked people that were you know
hands-on winning clients or finding
needed by example
yeah leading by example exactly that so
i fought for as long as i possibly could
to stay cold face and in
you know and doing the 360 job for as
long as i could and but round about when
i became sales director it was very very
hard to do the candidate side because
i'd come in in the morning and you know
someone was um sick or someone was
pregnant or someone was uh you know
someone hadn't turned up for work or
someone had um an issue with a client or
we were a loan contractor started to go
in business development or department
laws about to go in the parent business
so it wasn't through choice i went away
from the hands-on side and that
that hands-on sales manager uh became a
bit of a joke in the team because i
started doing the client side and the
hiring of staff and
moving away from the candidate side so
to this day they still gonna um
they still flag that as kind of uh
a jest
so it's quite funny you mentioned okay
but yeah
now my job i've moved away from the
candidate side a lot and if i can't do
it constantly let's write for a job i'll
know because i know the market really
really well i'll know if they're right
but i hand it over
but you still might
still might get involved in like
strategic business development or
supporting the teams on that side and
the account development and stuff like
that i'm still very hands on account
development and business development
okay so
what i do now is i go and when i hire
somebody i tend to give them you know
six months no real target because we're
a bit more and
a bit more forgiving at bright purpose
i'll give them six months to get up and
running um after month four if they're a
training consultant i within the four
months they've joined will usually sign
you know ten clients and or something
silly like that a large number and then
i take those clients and then i
i can't develop with them as a
resource and i see the men and i'll
slowly see myself out and let them run
that account and so i i do that on
repeat now so i just build desks on
repeat for business development that's
what i do i'll go to an elephant hunt uh
sme i won spot business and then i bring
in consultants and i slowly phase myself
out the process and then go do it for
somebody else that that's what i think a
sales director should be doing and on
the strategic level the strategic level
is easy i mean it's not it's not very
hard there's not a lot of rocket science
behind recruitment agencies
i know people like to make it
complicated but it really isn't that
complicated and but yeah i'm involved in
all the key decisions all the strategies
but the strategy is really really simple
we want to grow and our we want to grow
our contract book we want to increase
our our parent placements we want to win
more clients and we want to send more
cvs and the best way for me to do that
sales director is win more clients and
hire more staff so the strategy is
fairly set out from the start
okay
so let let's unpack this then so i'm
really keen so what we will go over is
your leadership journey because i think
that's a really common challenge for
people and then we'll talk a bit about
the business strategy or whatever
because i do feel like there's a bit
more to it than what you just said
but i get i go i get your point i get
your point entirely but what i just
wanted to focus on on
focus on very quickly is
you sort of saying um sort of you
building up desks for people and doing
that on repeat right
so a lot of people listen to this
may have come into the recruitment
industry in the last couple of years
and obviously it's quite typical for
them to start on the candidate side and
then start transitioning into
the 360 whatever it is right in terms of
winning your own clients building your
niche getting known all of that and that
can be a really difficult transition for
people which is why it makes sense that
if you can support someone in getting to
that point by as you said slowly but
surely passing things over getting them
involved on the journey showing them how
you go about it that can really help
them so what i want to know from you
then
is like
what can people listening to this do or
what do you think the best people do
when it comes to
really um doing that transition really
well so i might be someone right now
that supported kane on the resource
center
but now i need to start doing my own bdd
activity i need to start growing my own
accounts what do the the best recruiters
do well on that point do you think or
what do you think people should be doing
well
at transition stage um it might not be
very popular but the cold calling thing
is really really key because um
it really does shake that kind of tag
that kind of negative and sales tag off
your shoulders so i'm not going to sit
here and tell you that it's very
successful cold calling a business it's
not and even if i sat down now and pick
10 businesses i'm cold called and my
success rate would be low yeah however
in your first couple of years you don't
have a brand yet you don't have a name
yet you can't reference clients where
you put 30 40 people or
projects where you delivered 50
contractors i can do that now so my
elevator pitch and my credibility is
better and i've got references so it's
much easier for me to business
development but and year two and three
and year one two and three sorry when i
was i didn't have any reputation really
i was learning my trade and i had to win
my own clients i
did it the old-fashioned way and i would
you know target myself on five
pd calls a day where i'd go on linkedin
i'd map out the company i'd say right
it's a ct wanting to speak them go on
their website i'd get all their jobs i'd
pick one that i've been working recently
and i'd ask a candidate oh i'm speaking
i'm gonna speak to this client if
they're interested would you be happy
for me to introduce your resume et
cetera et cetera and then that's when
the client and elevator pitch now it's
not very successful doing it that way
but by doing that again and again and
again and again and again and for you
know 9 to 18 months after doing that for
19 months you have too much business
first of all you have you do have enough
success because it's a numbers game but
you also
turn the word sales into a positive
thing and you shake off that negative
tag and it also helps you value how how
valuable client is yeah you start to
require more respect because it was
really hard to win them in the first
place and then because you're thinking
more salesy and you're thinking and
you've started mapping out companies and
you're you're thinking of your elevator
pitch and you're trying to join dots so
they use hammer and well they use kotlin
and these swift and you start to build a
picture of the market you become more
credible so
even if your elevator pitch to one
mobile app company fails all that work
you've done you then understand oh well
they use they've got a team of seven ios
developers or
yeah so so by doing elevator pitches as
long as you prepare them right the the
information you learn through that prep
and and the kind of guts it takes to
make that call for the whole office
it becomes second nature obviously but
the guts it takes to make that first
call in front of all your friends and
your colleagues and try and win the
business of something you've never
smoked that's about a rush as well and
you you build you build credibility
because you get to know the market you
learn how to map out a client you learn
how to join dots and
it's not the most successful way of
doing it but over time the skills you
learn from doing it come in handy over
years and years and years so now
at the elevator which is just
in my head what does a good elevator
pitch look like mate
to me um you can it's very short and
snappy you you wonder trust straight
away you can reference somebody that
they know that knows you you can
reference similar clients that you work
with you can reference similar
technologies and that they're using our
projects that they're using and and you
know their business inside out you
sometimes you even know people in the
business that you place felt aware and
it's all about being able to reference
yourself to technologies and people
within their business and their clients
and and also kind of justifying why they
should speak to you you should speak to
me because i've just placed three ios
developers you've just won a project
with the bbc
st are my biggest client currently and i
have delivered their entire mobile team
just making them listen what making them
realize they need to speak to you above
anyone else and making them realize that
you can add value to what they're doing
and because the clients need clients
need recruiters and a lot of recruiters
don't really value themselves
clients really need recruiters to grow
their business because they'll have
pressure to deliver projects to deliver
products and
from a shareholder perspective
businesses will have you know pressures
to grow so the only way they're going to
grow is by recruiting the right people
so by speaking to me more often than not
in the tech space in scotland i'll help
them grow i will help them develop a
project and i'll help them deliver their
product so
i
the elevator pitch differs each time
yeah
well you spent five to ten minutes
building that out and then you you
you tweak it
yeah because you're doing that what what
advice would you have for people that uh
that really don't get struggled to get
over that hurdle of
um spending at least time each week
trying to speak to people that they
don't know
to try and yeah start to build a market
pitch all of that what's your advice to
help them overcome that because i'm sure
you've had this in your teams
yeah a hundred percent
listen see picking up the phone and cold
calling a client that's never heard of
you before it's dawning and i found it
and once i got on a roll i think they're
exciting not everybody not everybody
adapts to that then and to pretend to do
is nonsense so my advice is find what
works for you and if it's networking
great go to networking events if it's
brandon and you want to build on a
linkedin mark if you want to market
yourself to the market
do it but do it well you know what i
mean and i'm terrible i'm a technophobe
you go through my linkedin posts
they're not great i'm not the best
marketer but i'm brilliant at picking up
the phone and i'm brilliant at going to
events and i'm brilliant and going over
and just introducing myself explains
what's good for you some people are
brilliant copywriters and they can write
great emails
if that's really good that make sure
you're doing a lot of it and make sure
you actually
make sure you're make sure you're
thinking making your elevator pitches in
the email very salesy and very snappy
and very unique so
for me the cold calling thing was really
really good because uh
it's very daunting and and you don't
want to you don't want to be you don't
want to feel like a fool if that makes
sense on the call so you you have to
to not feel like when you have to do
your research yeah so
otherwise your life told the phone like
uh
and
it has happened to me by the way it's
half and it still does and don't think
for a second but it doesn't and so
think what's good think what works for
you think what's good for you and do it
and do it with good intentions and do it
on math as my advice yeah yeah okay so
before we move on to the leadership
piece then what obviously you've done
contract and perm obviously involved in
teams of new contract and perm
just just focusing on like doing good
real quick like what what do you believe
we'll do this for both right but what do
you believe is like the the one thing
that perm recruits let's start there
need to master to achieve sort of
consistent performance and why do you
think from your experience
yeah perhaps a slower process and it's
harder to find candidates in my
experience so i think
process is very important for power
recruiters finally enough they need to
make sure they're
they've got a consistent process you
know advert jobs linkedin
that they can do time and time again
exactly repeatable processes they know
that works and knowing their market as
well knowing exactly which clients yeah
behalf with people and really really
known that market really really well and
but yeah perm is a slower process and
and i find it easier to win business
than permanent actually so
um marketing your candidates and
permanent is much more important i think
because you can take a good prime
candidate and market them much easier
and because they're harder to find so
it's easier to sell in my in my
experience um but yeah for process is
really really important for pam and
taking your time candidates like you've
got to remember in perham as well as
it's a big move for a candidate yeah if
you're in a pro
and you i recruit our phones you only
give you one minute other time or two
minutes of their time are you really
gonna quit your job
i wouldn't i would i wouldn't quit my
job and put my mortgage at risk and my
kids at risk so if you're doing
permanent recruitment please seriously
yeah take it seriously listen then this
is people's lives we're talking about
and they might have been in this job for
10 15
contractors on the line yeah what what
one thing the contract recruiters really
need to master do you think
to get really really good speed urgency
speed
heartless and speed i've placed the same
contractors maybe five to six times um
and
i've also been given a contract role on
psl's and
where there's two or three of us and
that really is just a race there's maybe
35 people that the three recruiters know
and says go go go go go and so the
contract contract candidates in my
experience and they tend to not want to
be on the phone for 5-10 minutes
they tend to be limited companies and
they tend to be um
you know they tend to be like great
location working from home allowance
they tend to be quite short and direct
compared to param candidates palm
candidates need they they are and
they're leaving a permanent job for
another permanent job usually
contractors are usually in contract
they're out of contract so it's much
more transactional yeah
there's more transactional contractors
especially london may be different
because i know the job market moves a
lot more down there but in scotland
permanent candidates you know if they're
going to move it's a really really
serious decision for them so we treat
them
as that and remember
that they're gonna they're gonna take
their time they're going to reveal job
spec overnight contract candidates can
sometimes you can sometimes get the
right to represent on the phone always
get by email to avoid the bond fight but
you can sometimes get yeah what's the
client what's the rate yeah duration
tech stack oh oh yeah i know that person
yeah okay put me forward yeah you can
meet or contract candidates in my
experience because it's more
transactional but perm candidates
get that you mean get to know the name
of their dog if you can yeah yeah okay
so
just to tie this all together and let's
make it just i guess even more current
like if we think in the last 18 months
right in the journal that you've been on
and i know there's a few sort of quiet
sort of exciting changes that you've
experienced in that time with bright
purple right which we're going to talk
about but like just to sort of focus
still on like being good at recruiting
right now being successful consistent
performance like if you were to look at
your teams holistically over the last 18
months what what's been like the most
consistent and effective way for your
team to win business do you think
over the last 18 months really worked
yeah
um
it's not been hard to win business
because we've been in tech so i found
that the easiest
around about april time this year and
the tech market has been
more than it's ever been so it's been
quite easy to win business actually okay
um
picking up the phone going
going uh going events i mean there's
something many for the culverts but we
were at scotland last week for example
and we picked a business there and
keep keep doing what you're doing just
because you're working from home doesn't
i mean keeping the same work ethic as
you had in the office at home is the key
really but we're finding businesses not
really slowed down we've not had to do
much different than we did before we're
just we're just finding there's much
more business out there yeah yeah
engagement then we hired maybe maybe
it's because we hired a market in person
i don't know and maybe she's directly
linked to their recent success when yeah
we're marketing ourselves much better
and we're easier to find and because in
tech everyone's hiring so
we're not finding winning business as a
problem right now we're finding hiring
and enough staff to keep
clients are hard yeah and we're all
yeah we're finding finding permanent
candidates and i've got lots of offers
right now yeah a lot of options yeah
okay a lot of objects yeah okay cool so
let's go into let's go into this
leadership sort of journey right
so
because obviously it's a real big
challenge for a lot of people and a lot
of people listening to this will aspire
to be a director a leader at some point
in our recruitment career so like what
yeah what were some of the things you
had to learn the hard way so let's start
there like if we were to think in in
hindsight obviously you've had to learn
the hard way as you said you didn't have
loads of mentors on the leadership side
because a lot of people left like what
what did you have to learn the hard way
what did you find really difficult
firstly let's stop there when we were
starting when kane had to become more of
a leader a hands-on leader as you said
um
well not everyone's like me okay
so when you say that as in like you are
going in having the mindset why isn't he
doing that why isn't she doing that
because that's what you think you would
do okay so comparing people to your
standards who you are what you do first
part exactly okay i i i
as a leader you
you get
and recruitment is classic the the top
performers become managers and the top
performers aren't always managers
so for me it was a real journey where i
i i became a top performer through my
habits and my
way of doing things so when i tried to
you know impart that on people and some
people took it and we had similar
personalities and it was great others
others didn't and then
at first i was really confused and i
didn't really know how to manage them
and looking back i probably and i've
been on a bit of a journey and then and
i would manage them differently now
how would you map in what way what would
you do differently
well i would ask i would ask
and what i do now is ask them how do you
want the business develop how do you
want to manage your accounts and why do
you want to put them forward ask more
open questions instead of saying you're
going to do it this way
yeah but that's all i knew yeah yeah
and i was on a journey as well so to
speak so i i tried to kind of
impart how i've done it on them
and
they're they're different people and and
i'm an extrovert i think that comes
across whoever meets me so managing
introverts i would always be like oh
just call them
oh yeah just i just do this and then
slowly learn everybody's really
different and then and on accepting that
accepting that and now that now i have
accepted that because i've been in a
leadership role for you know seven years
now
i've managed so much probably so many
people know that
i do respect everyone's different and
everyone's got different roles within a
team whereas before i just wanted
everyone to be if we had a team if
everyone on brightpearl was like kane
webster and we'd be out of business yeah
we'd have no fun
we'd have no processes we'd have no the
finance team the financing was quite on
the day the past team was put on the
play
and so real
now i realize that yeah maro's great and
i i get a lot of you know like claps and
celebrated but the truth is i couldn't
do my job without them
i've only learned this in the last year
since i'm in a director role that the
value of a back office oh my god um i i
can't believe how much i undervalued
them when i wasn't in a director role um
and how much i didn't realize they did
for the
i feel like i business
like the name needs to change
back office
i don't know i just feel like the labels
like like you said they're behind
they're just behind the scenes they're
not i don't know i don't know what their
name is but i feel like it has that
interpretation of like oh they're just
there dude then like they just do the
finance whatever as you said like
they're so [ __ ] important for the
whole thing it's so important
honestly so important and you know i
looking back again i've probably annoyed
them all and i've probably not taken
enough time to to realize how annoying i
am
do you know what i mean i just full of a
client or fool of my new contractor or
full of my new parent placement they're
like well how do i invoice game i'm like
i don't know like and looking back
i look at it now and think oh yeah so so
so that's a quite common challenge that
you've shared like yeah expecting people
to do what you would do what else would
did you find challenging then on the
leadership journey that maybe you had to
work through
um when you become a leader or our
director our sales manager you you have
to accept people have personal lives and
okay so
there's a lot of things that kind of
you have to deal with that you that
aren't part of your remit if that makes
sense people have peaks and troughs in
their personal life so you have to
remember people have got a work persona
and an out of work persona yeah and
sometimes you'd have a top performer
that would just fall off a cliff
or you'd have someone that wasn't doing
so well just skyrocket and and the
reality is that they start telling you
things because you've known them from
years at points they start telling you
things are going on your personal life
and and you you do end up it doesn't end
up impacting you if someone's having a
really hard time personally and they
confide in you like okay and this has
happened in my family and
you do carry that around a little bit
sometimes so switching off and and
having because when you're managing 20
people 20 sales staff
obviously those 20 people are going to
be going for different journeys
some will be in a new relationship and
if be totally boy and totally happy
others will be going through a divorce
others will have a death in the family
yeah so dealing with that
yeah exactly that so having to
you haven't haven't gone from like a
lone wolf consultant into like managing
20 people where when you when you're
managing team of four or five that
happens every couple of months you have
to have like a really
heartfelt conversation but when you're
managing 20 sales staff you you haven't
haven't have those conversations you
know maybe once a month now and the real
people i've got real lives with real
stuff impacting their work so and it's
good
mental health's been a big thing lately
in the last couple years and it's really
come out so it's been much more open and
it's been a much more open environment
to talk about and ask what what we'll
ask why someone's not as more not as
engaged on the calls or not as you know
not working as like these they're
working
not that they should for example but
it's it's a much more open environment
to have that conversation which is a
good thing but
with that more open conversation as a
leader and as a director or a manager
you you do you do take some of it home
if you yeah you carry something around
it and so
learning to try i'm still trying to
switch off after work sometimes to be
honest with you and but
yeah it's hard it's hard because you
care about these people
they're your friends and your staff yeah
so you really do
yeah 100 so before you go into like the
the sort of business
strategy side of things you've learned
there just
just curious
so all the things you're talking about
there all those channels that you can
sort of experience as a hands-on billing
manager all these types of things yeah
what that can also sometimes mean is
that you end up earning less money
with more responsibility more headaches
so what are your i don't know if you're
thinking about us at the moment it's
just one of the conversations i've been
having with a few people recently like
what is such like there's no way
brightpearl will get to where they get
to without those five people or more
people like that in your business right
so how
i don't know when i say to you how do
you think that billing manager that
hands on billing leader role could be
uh what's the word reward it or like i
don't know how how i don't know does
anything come up for you when we think
how could that person be incentivized in
a different way or i don't know does
anything come up for you on that that
you're thinking about of interest
yeah yeah we i'm very lucky so obviously
i'm the sales director but i've got a
ceo nick price who's running this
business for 26 years and he he is an
idea factory so when i say the strategy
part is easy it's because i've got
someone just throwing ideas at me
constantly yeah and all i need to do is
pick one of the good ideas and because
the guy the guy is
fascinating he's got like a got he could
have two or three great ideas in a day
so all i need to do is pick the one that
i want to get behind and go with it so
um he comes up with a lot of strategy if
i'm being honest with you and i'm going
to execute it so i i find it easy
because i've got someone doing that for
me and i just have to kind of i kind of
have to agree with the one after the one
i agree with most and then go with it
but on the bill and manager side yeah
it's
you can earn less money for a more
stressful job but but at the same time
it is more rewarding um
as financially rewarding as it should be
but that was
that
yes at bright purple we've got our
system so we we've we've been dealing
with this problem because all the five
guys and girls you mentioned they have
got um
they've got personal targets that
they're exceeding all the time yeah
they're also managing a team however um
what we've done is we've incentivized
them on our team performance so as long
as they hit their own target and
everyone in their team is 70 percent to
target and that way
[Music]
and we might change that in april and
we're constantly looking at that yeah
yeah
yeah
because you're right
i actually definitely see that but
you do get more rewarding yeah no i can
see that it's just more of like most
people wouldn't go it's more rewarding
but i don't feel like why i should sort
of financially
take like a hit on it you know what i
mean because that so i just think it
should be more we should be more
innovative with how we can reward those
people you know
oh my god
based wage is obvious ones you get an
interest in your base wage but it
usually doesn't equate to how much
commission you would have made if you
were just taking all the time of
one-on-ones and training and hiring
all that time to put in to fill in jobs
you might make more in commission it's
the truth and so what we're trying to do
is we're trying to do quarterly um
bonuses but i work in the managers where
um as long as they hit their target and
everyone in our team is at least 70 to
their target they'll get a much bigger
bonus that's where we're at today that
will change yeah and we just we look at
it constantly yeah you're right it's a
very it's the hardest maybe one of the
hardest jobs in recruitment running a
team of five or six good recruiters and
it's one of the hardest yeah so yeah we
look out all the time so let's talk
about kane the sales director then as we
come to the end here
um
one of the most common questions i get
is around and this like you said you i
love the fact that you around your
mindset around tech and tools and stuff
like that what what have been some of
the
things you guys have invested in that
you think you probably couldn't live
without
now out of interest on the tool side oh
yeah yeah well
i'll shamelessly plug source
well i mean i can't believe i used to
have to log into four or five different
job boards to look for what why so just
talk us through about how it's had an
impact like in in like real recruitment
life why why has it been
so good well
well they came to us and they've done a
demo and i was i mean we we
we get pitched all the time yeah um
and
this was probably two or three years ago
and they came and they were like oh yeah
we aggregate all your job so i was like
well what do you mean and then they came
and said look you think job site told
you yeah job service
one job
and instead of logging into the mall and
having a log in and you know and like
logging in logging out and sharing and
all this kind of stuff you just log into
breaker and i was like okay log in i
mean they're all there all your job
boards in one tab and they don't repeat
themselves so source breaker has really
taken a lot of the kind of
double work out of scrolling job boards
we now just use one job we have lots of
job boards which show on one job
and how does that happen how does that
help the guys and girls and is it on the
bd side is it candidate side is it both
candidate side because they're only
having to log into one right um platform
source breaker and what it does is it
puts all the job boards and candidates
into one form right and it doesn't
require games all right so it's great so
you're instead of walking into five
different yeah so saving the shitload
this time basically yes instead of being
john smith on all five job boards i'm
going up after him
before oh yeah
so we just got all there it's perfect
also it builds leads now i personally um
do most of my dd from kind of like
referrals from candidates and i'm gonna
go where you classic you know i think
i'll work a role you know when i was
hands on before the team
is yeah i would work a role and i'd get
three good candidates send them over and
textbook recruitment
while finding those candidates i'd get
where else are where else are you
interviewing
candidates and they would tell me then i
would pick with the candidates that were
more suitable for these other clients
and i'd approach them and elevator pitch
okay but source breaker if you're if
you're not so good and you don't feel
comfortable asking where people are
interviewing you can click a button
which changes your candidate search into
and job leads and it brings up all
instead of having to go through
competitors websites in fact figure out
what is that financial service client in
the middle of edinburgh
instead of having to do that that kind
of um you know inspector mode and you
can you've got source breaker and you
have the same bully in search and you
type candidates then you type jobs and
it goes here's all the jobs and here's
all the clients that have jobs matching
that job matching that kind of billions
yeah and it's like oh scanner
yeah it comes all up in one place yeah
and it's like god i don't even have to
actually get market leads from talking
to candidates anymore i can literally
just click a button
yeah yeah that's what over the times
you've really got to know yeah yeah so
talk to me about one of the other things
that's been quite pivotal for you guys
is this remote team right
for the remote team in terms of the last
18 months so
talk to us about this journey because i
think this is still a talking point
you're obviously a business based in
scotland i know you've had offices in
different parts of the world throughout
your journey
but talk to us about what you've learned
so far the positives maybe some of the
challenges on you building out this
fully remote team although your your
business hq's in in scotland
yeah well first of all i'm gonna
apologize on behalf of
the entire world who didn't embrace
remote working before and i was one of
those people
so i'm just going to apologize about it
at least you can own that right
yeah i would apologize of having 90
percent of directors even if they don't
know they should apologize
and i was a sales director and if you'd
asked me and can we run this business
remotely i would have laughed
yeah good one
yeah whatever as i've
covered taught as we could and luckily
and my finance director gemma brown and
the ceo and nick price they were
probably the same opinion and jeremiah
brown was a bit more forward-thinking
than me and nick but um we just didn't
think he could work remotely and we were
constantly going to board meetings
constantly saying let's grow this
business yeah and then how are we going
to grow it well we're going to hire more
recruiters what we're going to offer
them we're going to offer them five days
a week ahead of time
the same as what everyone else is
offering exactly the time
yeah exactly same then we come back few
months later and go how many staff have
we hired two
we said
they retired ten ah well we interviewed
ten but those ten had uh oh those ten
had you know six other offers and what
were they offering they were offering
nine to five office based edinburgh 30k
base and 30k target and shock horror and
we couldn't grow and we just couldn't
grow
and looking back it's absurd isn't it
and
it's just absurd like the definition of
insanity is doing the same thing
we were every born meeting going in
saying we want to grow we had full
intentions of growing and we were going
out and we were you know hiring but we
were hiring maybe we were grown by maybe
five percent a year in terms of staff
and it's because we were making this
requirement of you have to be in office
at nine and if you're five minutes late
i mean we weren't that bad we weren't
draconian but you know you're five
minutes late people it wasn't it was an
option for you guys you didn't it wasn't
so what have you what have you learned
so far what have you learned so far then
since going down this path of a fully
remote team i've learned
i'm learning retention of staff is much
higher we're not really people aren't
really resigning retention yeah
the pension is key what's the point in
hiring five staff if you lose five years
what's the
point about what about productivity
what does that look like well
yeah productivity is good results are
good i would say people i was it's funny
because when you worked in office i
looked back there and i think god and
we're like
our results are better than ever so
people are working the hours they need
to work to get the job done whereas when
you're in the office i remember on
fridays even even when i was sales
director and sales manager or team
leader consultant
on a friday at three we weren't really
looking back
it was draconian it was whether we liked
them there or not we were we were not
working we were not in office to work we
were we were in the office because we
were contracted to be there nine till
five yeah
and so what i found is productivity has
increased because i would i would
suggest on average
and people might be doing slightly less
hours if you include travel and so
productivity is increased if you include
travel but people are people are working
smarter people are working with some
people are getting a job and they're
working it there and then and then
they're getting up late the next morning
and starting later
what about
what about some challenges so far then i
think one of the biggest question marks
is
with this team do we feel like we can we
can cultivate a bright purple culture
within this team
like what do you mean there are more
yeah the remotes in the remote team
sorry yeah it's like what's been because
i think that's what a lot of people are
thinking about
just to give you a bit of context but i
mean we are eighty percent even in
scotland so we've got an office which is
not really flexible people can come in
with that so yeah yeah we've got
flexibility if you if you've you know if
you want to take for example if you want
to take your child to a swimming class
yeah yeah attend living just let your
manager know and make up louder we're
quite flexible and as long as you're in
office one day a week to try and keep
that culture going for now we will look
at that again in april next year i think
um but right now it's one day a week and
so we are quite flexible across the
board and we're eighty percent remote
across
the hundred percent more team don't
answer your question directly and we
went down to london last week or the
week before and we got them all together
we went on a speed boat down the thames
that was brilliant and we got them
together we have them in weekly wash ups
and we're coming up to heaven for the
christmas party okay so it's like
creating moments like that then and
being making the effort
we've certainly yeah and
well funny you say that but both the
remote both of the people that joined
the remote team stewart and umar and
they had other offers from other
recruitment agencies and and the reason
they joined very purple is because we
came down from edinburgh
never trained in london then i went down
at broadway south and east
had dinner and then he
accepted our offer and turned another
both of them said you actually took the
time to come down
and you know me meet me and actually
show me that you cared and another
recruiting agency didn't do that so the
lesson for us is we're going to keep
doing that and every time i go to a
meeting in london i want to make sure
the remote team meet me there um every
time there's a big event like our
christmas party or an either fringe
event or an end of the year social we
will pay for them and come up and we'll
get them a hotel and yeah and we will
make effort because
staff retention is the key in all
recruitment agencies
it should be it should be just i think
sometimes it isn't as much thought about
as it is getting people like like you
said in those in those board meetings
you didn't say
how can we keep all the people we have
you said how can we get 10 more people
do you know i'm
the thing is
right
spot on and then that is changing that
like the world is moving in a better
direction with that i mean there's a
great graph but i mean it's like how
much you value something and when you
have it and it's like down here right
okay yeah yeah we don't have it right
yeah yeah i mean
and it's so true yeah and i i constantly
remind myself of that you know if i was
interviewing some of my leadership team
now or some of my good consultants and
senior consultants and principals are
good resources et cetera and
i'd be paying their hand off me trying
to get them in the business as fast as i
can so i constantly remind myself of
that graph of like how much you value
something when you have it versus how
much you value someone you don't so yeah
and protect retention's key
so
as we finish then what what's what's on
the bright purple horizon mate what are
you excited about talk to us before we
finish what's what's going on really
excited about tomorrow
tomorrow and obviously we had a kind of
remote day away in london last week
tomorrow we're going to bundy um with
the with the kind of the scottish based
recruit okay
wet and wild we're going on a wet and
wild assault course and and we're going
for a curry after that we did it we did
a staff survey so basically what drives
us is our staff survey and our staff
survey told us that they wanted um that
we give christmas in a year off for free
so they told us they want so we gave
them their birthday off for free next
year and they also said they with remote
work and they want more kind of
building exercises
so we are investing a lot of time and
effort and money into if we're not going
to meet each other you know every day in
the office and we're only going to see
each other once a week or maybe less
because they're not only the same time
let's really get creative so we've got
we've got wet and wild tomorrow in
dundee we've got um a big christmas
party coming up which i won't say just
now in case the team here because jeremy
brown is working on it and when we're
the remote team will be coming up for
that which i'm really excited about
we'll get together and then in february
we're doing the great gatsby ball on a
saturday night which we're all doing so
we we we're really we've downsized our
office because of remote working and
flexibility and we're taking the money
saved in the office yes yeah amazing
yeah exactly that so there's an event
almost every month for every second
month for bright purple right now and to
keep that culture going that you talked
about and and to keep the remote team
engaged and the good thing about the
remote team is we can scale up as quick
as we want now because because we're
hiring fully remote we can scale this
business up as quick as our clients
demand i mean and we've got five we've
got five offers out right now with
consultants and because they're flexible
working and we've got no one resigning
so it's really really having that remote
team just buys us that kind of and
it buys us that bandwidth to grow as
quick as we want yeah
just really exciting
i can tell yeah hopefully
hopefully people are going to accept the
offers we've got with them and i'm
hopefully not going to make too much of
a fool of myself in this wet and wild
tomorrow
and hope and hopefully i don't get too
drunk at the christmas party that that's
basically i love it
well look no that's okay it's been
absolute pleasure love your energy love
your positivity i think there's there's
loads to take away from here from
chucking yourself into it perseverance
working out what works for you just yeah
creating your own luck being willing to
yeah like get out of your comfort zone
try different things be open-minded um
but yeah honestly thanks so much for
coming on the pod really excited to see
where you guys are over the next couple
of years
yeah thank you for having me and and the
last bit of advice i'll give to anyone
listening to this on the startup journey
is sticking
sometimes you'll feel like you're not
doing that well but you don't know how
well our people are doing and it is a
journey it really really is a journey so
stick in what you're doing and then and
believe in yourself because then
there's lots of successful recruiters
out there and so it is very very
achievable yeah i love it ken thank you
thank you all the best bye